I EXPLAINED TO BRUCE THAT
WE NEEDED TO CONVINCE CUSTOMERS
THEY SOMEHOW CONTRACTED
A DISEASE THEY'RE LIKELY
TO DIE FROM.
BRUCE RELUCTANTLY AGREED
TO LET ME TRY IT OUT FOR A DAY.
AND AFTER A WEEK OF PREPARATION,
MY ACTORS WERE READY.
IT WAS TIME FOR PEOPLE TO ENTER
THE WORLD'S SCARIEST
HAUNTED HOUSE.
WELL, THANKS FOR COMING
TO THE REIGN OF TERROR.
- OH, WE'RE EXCITED, MAN.
- YOU'RE EXCITED?
- YEAH, MAN.
- I HAVE TO WARN YOU
BEFORE YOU GO IN.
- OH, DANG.
- THIS HAUNTED HOUSE
IS EXTREMELY SCARY.
- I LIKE THE SOUND OF THAT.
- ARE YOU SURE?
- YEAH.
- ALL RIGHT, WELCOME
TO THE REIGN OF TERROR.
- YOU FIRST.
[air hissing]
[shrieks]
- OOH...
- MOMMY.
- HELLS....
- YOU'RE MY MOMMY.
- [screams]
[both laugh]
[chainsaw buzzing]
- [screams]
- [growls]
- AAH!
- [roars]
- [evil laugh]
- [laughs]
- SORRY, ONE SEC.
WHAT? WHO?
WHO? HER?
- YEAH.
- SORRY, CAN YOU
COME WITH ME FOR A SEC?
SORRY, GUYS.
WERE YOU GUYS SCARED IN THERE?
- YEAH.
- SO SORRY, DID SHE
TOUCH YOU BY ANY CHANCE?
OR WAS THERE A--
- UM, I THINK SHE PROBABLY
TOUCHED MY NECK.
- MOMMY!
- [screams]
[slow-motion laughter]
- LIKE, I USUALLY
WEAR MY GLASSES
AND THIS TIME I DIDN'T,
AND I OVERSHOT THE GRAB
AND I WAS SUPPOSED
TO NOT TOUCH YOU.
- WAIT, SORRY, JUST--
- SORRY.
- CAN YOU GUYS
WAIT IN HERE ONE SEC?
- YEAH.
- SORRY, ONE SECOND.
- WHAT IS IT CALLED?
- IT'S CALLED KLEIN'S DISEASE.
AND IT'S AN IMMUNITY--
- KLEIN DISEASE?
- KLEIN'S DISEASE.
- SO WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
- SHE HAS AN AUTO-IMMUNE THING.
SHE WORRIED WHEN
SHE TOUCHED YOU,
SHE TRANSMITTED
SOMETHING TO YOU.
- MM-HM.
- SO DON'T GET FREAKED OUT
OR ANYTHING,
BUT I CALLED AN AMBULANCE.
PARAMEDICS ARE JUST
COMING TO MAKE SURE.
THEY'LL LOOK AT YOU,
IT'S JUST PRECAUTIONARY.
SO JUST HOLD TIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
- NO PROBLEM.
- I HOPE YOU HAD A GOOD TIME
IN THE HAUNTED HOUSE.
SORRY ABOUT THIS.
- IT'S ALL GOOD.
- HEY, GUYS.
- HEY.
- UH, JUST IN HERE.
- DO YOU HAVE ANY CUTS
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT?
- I DON'T THINK SO.
I DON'T LOOK BACK THERE A LOT.
[laughter]
- OKAY, DO YOU MIND
IF I JUST--
WE SHOULD DEFINITELY
GET HER CHECKED OUT, IF THAT'S--
- YEAH.
- "CHECKED OUT" IN WHAT WAY?
- LIKE, AT A HOSPITAL
WITH A DOCTOR FOR SURE,
FOR KLEIN'S.
[sirens wailing]
- TO MY KNOWLEDGE, IT'S
A DISEASE THAT'S PRETTY SERIOUS.
BASICALLY, IF YOU'VE GOT A CUT,
AND YOU'RE TOUCHED,
AND YOU HAVE ANY SORT
OF OPEN WOUND OR ANYTHING THAT,
YOU KNOW, TOUCHED AN ORIFICE--
YOUR EYE, YOUR MOUTH,
OR ANYTHING THAT'S OPEN
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
- JEEZ.
- YEAH.
IT CAN BE CONTRACTED, SO--
- IS THIS, LIKE, AIDS?
IS IT, LIKE--WORSE?
- WELL, IT IS AN IMMUNE
DEFICIENCY DISEASE.
- [sighs]
- YEAH?
OKAY.
- WHAT'S THAT MEAN?
- HOW ARE WE DOING?